welcome my name is Austin and I'm an
engineer on the cloud sequel team in
this video I'll show you how to create
run and manage sequel instances using
Google Cloud sequel cloud sequel helps
manage mundane administrative tasks from
my sequel and Postgres databases so you
can focus on what matters let's walk
through how to create a Postgres
database on cloud sequel and connect to
it from the Google cloud shell you can
set up an instance in just a few steps
we'll start with the basics and I'll
point out some options for additional
configuration along the way we'll start
by navigating to cloud sequel in the GCP
console and clicking create instance
will select Postgres and press next
we'll give the instance a name and let's
not forget to set the password for our
default account this instance will be
created in the US and we'll leave the
zone set to any so cloud sequel can
choose for us let's take a look at the
configuration options you can specify
instance size high availability and more
for this demo I'll choose 4 CPU cores
and then maximize the memory maximizing
memory is a good choice for Postgres
because it can take advantage of the
extra memory for performance that said
don't worry too much about initial
sizing you can scale the instance up or
down later let's increase the storage
capacity to 200 gigabytes because
increasing disk capacity also increases
performance check out the performance
calculator below as I add capacity my
disk performance increases which will
allow my database to process more
operations per second and now enable
automatic storage increase so that I
don't accidentally run out of disk space
lastly let's ensure that the database
will automatically provide isolation
from failures we can do that by enabling
the high availability configuration
which for Postgres will automatically
fail over to another zone in the case of
an outage now that we're happy with the
configuration of our instance let's kick
off the creation it may take a few
minutes for your instance to create this
is a great time to grab a quick cup of
coffee you can also check the status of
your instance by navigating to your
instance list once you see a green
checkmark your instance is ready looks
like our instance has finished creating
let's open the details page to continue
there are many ways to connect to this
instance within GCP for example we could
use App Engine compute engine or
container engine but we could also
connect from just about anywhere by
authorizing IP addresses or using the
cloud sequel proxy for this demo I'll
connect using the Google cloud shell
cloud shell provides command-line access
to all of your cloud resources such as
cloud sequel instances directly from the
browser to open the cloud shell click
connect using cloud shell as you can see
the relevant g-cloud command to connect
to your cloud sequel instance has been
pre typed for us so all we need to do is
press Enter
and then enter our root password from
before and now we're connected so let's
add some data I'll create a table and
we'll insert a few rows
finally I'll make sure the data is now
in our database
and it is great so to recap in the last
few minutes we just created a cloud
sequel instance with high performance
and high availability and connected to
it with cloud shell now that you've seen
how to get started give it a try you can
learn more about Google Cloud sequel and
our free trial program here thank you
for watching